the jurogan experience we were just
talking about uh you know tim dillon and
i were just talking about um
virtual
cities and virtual real estate and
people moving into the metaverse if it
starts looking like that
ready player one is going to be a
documentary
i mean what's crazy about the metaverse
everyone's freaking out about it but
it's already kind of been going on for a
long time like that virtual red band
[ __ ] that i do that's what i do every
single night i have a fake character i
have a fake homeworld i have a bunch of
friends we all go online go hey let's go
to disney world and then we'll go to
disney row and just ride roller coasters
and then let's go to a bar we'll go to a
bar we could go to strip club it's kind
of already when you do it how many
people do you have that are watching
with you uh well the watching thing uh
it's probably like i do it on youtube
twitch and uh twitter and comm it's not
much it's like a couple thousand and
stuff like that but i do it almost every
night and people are now buying like
oculuses and stuff and trying to join me
in the world so can they join you in the
world yeah i mean a lot of times if i'm
not feeling like it i'll hide and you
know
uh but yeah i i mean we streamed out
like what levels we're on and and
everything like that so if you do put an
oculus on and you do like go into the
world you can invite people to it so you
could have a virtual show right in the
wow it's amazing yeah i do stand-up
comedy in it
yeah there's comedy clubs and there's
even open mics where there's like
sometimes like like 40 people in the
room strangers and we're all waiting in
line backstage like i'm next i'm next
and do you all have avatars yeah so you
could look like big bird and you could
be sitting there right right wow yeah
and that's another whole career that's
opening up is people that can make those
avatars which is like they're going to
be a hot commodity in the future making
artists that can make avatars for you
because i mean i paid this guy to make i
wanted wendy from wendy's but i wanted
big tits with areolas you could see
through it a little and like those
little dots that are on there i even
paid for the little dots around the
nipples and stuff like that
i want to see what it looks like
yeah you can find it just virtual red
band but uh
and it's crazy and
like i'm thinking about like what
upgrades i want to my fake self you know
in the future like i want to have it so
people could like tug on my hair and
stuff oh really
and that as they do that they can like
as the technology advances or is just
have to give different artists do it
like how do you yeah you could just you
pretty much it's that's like a career
like somebody that knows how to
photoshop uh where you know how to go
into your avatar make new bones you know
change the textures around put it in
blender and upgrade it like i did the
most basic
things like i made myself a little bit
taller and a little smaller like i have
one that's like this big like tiny windy
so i can like look up girls dresses and
stuff
it's not a real dress so it's cool it
hasn't been camp you can't be canceled
before matt yet so this is you yeah
that's my friend yonder he works uh at
vulcan you're the big guy that has a
beard you know him in real life that's
hilariously he's an an elf or a merlin
yeah he's merlin from or sorting the
stone i think he oh okay uh so this is
it's kind of still cartoony yeah this is
boba fett
uh oh wow boba fett's uh somebody i hang
out with like every night okay that's
elon musk so these people are all in
their own home and they meet at this
place and you interact in this
environment and there's
are there like clips like can you move
through that table or does the table
block your motion right right he's
sitting down right now and now you can
like jump on the table you want like
this is a sushi bar where there's sushi
on a on a belt and we're ordering sushi
right now and having virtual sushi while
talking about vaginas and [ __ ] probably
and so when you're sitting here like
what do you have to be doing anything
physically like is it mapping your body
or yeah well you could do uh vr sitting
or standing and like you know boba boba
right there uh that guy on the right
yeah that's my friend jay he works for
tesla he just moved here from san
francisco he
engineered tesla and the way jay's
moving his hands is he moving his real
hands yeah he's moving his real hands
and then it maps it somehow yeah yeah i
have trackers all around my room i also
have trackers on my arms that i can use
i never use it though it's so much
easier because we're all drinking and
smoking and so it's easier just to like
sit down and hang out with your friends
right so there's like a sit down mode
where you can just use like
you know just kind of chill and play
this is [ __ ]
and this is
it's really interesting something has
taken off over the last two or three
years
it's strange to me i'll be honest with
you so grand theft auto role-playing is
what it's called yeah people have taken
grand theft auto and put it on their own
servers so like it's not they're not
hosting it or anything like that and
some ways they could probably take it
off the internet if they wanted to but
because it's keeping people involved in
grand theft auto they're they sort of
allow it but each character you're
seeing on right here is someone on the
internet
and they're acting as though they are
these people
and there are some people act like
police yeah they go police ones are the
laws the police ones are the best
because these people actually talk all
the codes that real cops use like they
know them like we got 37 over here we go
okay call the ambulance like fake fake
cops that are that always get arrested
in real life they have the powers where
these people live all of these people
are fake cops oh my god that's so weird
they can ruin the fun for you if you're
not following the laws they can kick you
off the server and you can't come back
for a few days yeah really you get
arrested and then you have to spend time
in jail and people have ruined
relationships because they like this
more than hanging out with their
girlfriends what it's pretty much like
vr chat same same style so this is
that this is crazy
so
they have rules yeah oh yeah grand theft
auto though is all about like killing
hookers with a crowbar yeah but the
server's rules so like it's just like
when you created a quake server you know
how you you can make your own rules now
like you're playing we played a 500 in
this room and it's all headshots only oh
yeah that's cool it's the same kind of
thing but it's grand theft auto in this
case vr chat we play pool like every
night we just sit there and play pool
and smoke we do in real life and talk
and like [ __ ] with each other it's
like it's like you know what reminds me
joe of the old message board days 100
wow 100
this is wild man so when you spend all
this time in here talking with all these
friends
and you're playing pool and you're
accumulating things how do you prove it
that you own that or you you know how do
you store it so that someone take it
when you're gone right like and that's
where this is if you have a phone and
you play subway surfer you could [ __ ]
get like really far on subway surfer
like really far and accumulate all this
power and everything but then
if you lose your phone and you have to
start from scratch you don't pick up
where you left off
it's not on that phone
right that happens on some things
so on this they would have to make it
somehow where whoever you are whatever
you accumulate in that world you can't
just lose it if you lose your phone
well the good thing is is if you
i mean i have like my files for my
character wendy with the big tits i have
her i haven't seen wendy yet
where's wendy oh you haven't showed him
the tits yet
uh did the one last night uh birthday
toe do that one because i talk about it
a lot good is the character getting is
it getting better looking oh yeah
mine's actually mine's actually
very basic because it's based off windy
from windy's so i don't want to make it
realistic and then no one gets the idea
right so mine is uh my my girl has a
good body and stuff
uh
but
and my girlfriend plays with us and
she's a hot dog so it's so funny like
we'll sit there and like have real like
arguments
uh talking who's spiderman oh that was
me last night wow that's a dope outfit
yeah it has every spider spider-man
character in there you could choose any
spider-man character is that crazy
there's been so many spider-mans like
where when did they start doing that
they never did that with anything else
like they did one time i think marvel
had a hulk that was like a bad hulk
right remember that
wasn't there like two hoaxes yeah there
was a greyhawk remember the greyhawk was
it a gray hall yeah there was like more
than one hulk for sure spider-man's got
into the multiverse i know from the
metaverse
i know the the that one uh cartoon
though is really [ __ ] good that one
animated spider-man into the metaverse
that's [ __ ] really good it's my
favorite i sent you the uh sequel the
the preview for the sequel remember the
other day that's right yeah that [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh there's there's me okay look at
my tits
you can see the shadows you can see it
yeah who made that for you uh gigi my
friend gd in canada shout out to gigi in
canada that's my girlfriend janice this
was last night at midnight we made a
surprise birthday party for her so we
like had all these balloons and
and writing and she just came in
thinking that she was just gonna play vr
and we were like surprised do you think
you can get in trouble for these uh
giant tits he put on wendy no because
anybody would find it that's actually
just grease of hamburger grease on my on
my pancake nipples
just
the fact that she's i mean you know
you're taking a like a copyright that's
actually not wendy that's just a
redheaded girl oh that's bo beep right
yeah no no no it's uh uh
han wait what's the other one
napo
pippy
yeah that's little red that's wendy
from no alice
yeah
so this is what the future looks like
this is the beginning this is pong
right yeah
spawn so this pong where you're like
whoa
cool you can do it remember for people
don't remember when uh i was younger
i mean uh brian is younger than me so i
was uh i probably
got this first
i think we were like
what was i like eight or nine
when we got one of those things attached
to tv when you could lay boop boop boop
and you had a dial that you could turn
and the dial would lift the paddle up
and down and you could hopefully catch
the ball and make it ricochet over to a
place where your the guy you're playing
couldn't get to it right and we were
blown away yeah and it was the basic
things too like there's two different
levels there's like fast and slow
remember no yeah
and the fact that we're moving things on
the internet or on the television you
actually can move it
so this is like the internet's version
of that